[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم عبد القادر عياد
وتطور اخرى في مناطق مختلفه من العالم
نبدا من العاصمه البرازيليه وهذه الصور
قبل قليل الاقتحام انصار الرئيس السابق
جرير بورسونارو مبانيه حكوميه بينها
البرلمان ضمن انشطه رافضه لعوده الرئيس
اليسرى الى السلطه
ثم هذه الصور من الخرطوم التي انطلقت فيها
مشاورات باشراف الامم المتحده والاتحاد
الافريقي ومجموعه الايجاد هذه المشاورات
تستمر اربعه ايام وتبحث قضايا المرحله
النهائيه من العمليه السياسيه في السودان
ثم الى بريشتينا وهذه الصور كوسوفو تعيش
ازمه جديده من تجلياتها مظاهره للاقليه
الصربيه في الجنوب احتجاجا على اطلاق
النار او ده بحياه شخصين وفي الشباب
المحاضل صربيا ايضا هو ليس ايضا
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
انصار الرئيس البرازيلي السابق جيرمان
يقتحمون البرلمان والقصر الرئاسي ومقر
الحكومه وساحه المحكمه الفيدراليه العليا
[تصفيق]
برعايه الامميه وافريقيه انطلاق المرحله
النهائيه من العمليه السياسيه السودان بعد
شهر من توقيع الاتفاق الاطاري الاطراف
المشاركه تؤكد ان الاتفاق حظيه بدعم كبير
من القوه السياسيه والمجتمع الدولي
والاقليلي والقوه الحريه والتغيير الكتله
الديمقراطيه تجدد رفضها وتتعاهد بتحريك
الشارع لاسقاط الاتفاق الايطالي
في ضربه وصفتها بالانتقاليه موسكو تعلل شن
هجوم فيكرامترس تقول انه ادى لمقتل 600
جندي اوكراني
وكيف تنفي وتشدد على ان الجيش الروسي لا
يملك القدرات الكافيه لتوجيه ضربات بتلك
الدقه وعلى وقع التصعيد صفقه لتبادل
الاسرى تضمنت 100 جندي من الطرفين
توتر المستمر في كوسوفو بعد سلسله
اشتباكات بين السلطات والاقليه الصربيه
مظاهره جديده للاقليه بعد اصابه شاب وطفل
برصاص الشرطه وبالقرار تقول ان النيته رفض
طلب صربيا بنشر الف عنصري في شمالي كسبه
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على بنساتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا معكم انطلاقه المشاورات في
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم وعلى مدى اربعه
ايام مشاورات في اطار المرحله النهائيه
للعمليه السياسيه في البلاد وقد قالت
الاليه ثلاثيه الميسرا للحوار في السودان
والمشكله من الاتحاد الافريقي ومجموعه
الايجاد وكذلك بعثه الامم المتحده قالت ان
هذه المرحله سيحرها البدنيون وكذلك
العسكريون المواقعون على اتفاق الايثار
السياسي في الخامس من ديسمبر الماضي
رايكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا
عليكم السؤال التالي برايكم ما مستقبل
العمليه سياسيه على ضوء المشاورات الحاليه
في السودان 20% توقعوا تحقيقه تقدم بينما
توقع 41 في المئه اي يزداد الوضع تعقيدا
ورجح 39% انت تمر البلاد بحاله من الجهود
السياسيه هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على
منصتنا الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت
عبر مسح رمز
الظاهر على الشاشه
لقاؤنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
تتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا
وكذلك دوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
لاول مره منذ ثلاث سنوات الصين تنهي اخر
القيود صارمه لمجابهه كورونا وتفتح الحدود
[موسيقى]
نبدا بالتطورات في البرازيل فقد اقتحمى
محتجونه مؤيدونا للرئيس البرازيلي السابق
جونارو اقتحام القصر الرئاسي ومقر الحكومه
وكذلك مبنى البرلمان ومبنى المحكمه
الفيدراليه في العاصمه برازيليه وذلك رفضا
لتنصيب الرئيس لولا دا سيلفا وتخلل
الاقتحام مواجهتهم بين المحتجين والشرطه
وقطع المحتجون عدد من الطرق في برازيليا
واستخدمت قوه الشرطه الغاز المثيره للدموع
لتفريقيا المحتجين
جدير بالذكر ان الرئيس سيلفا غير موجود
داخل القصر الرئاسي في برازيليا
هذا وكان الرئيس السابق جرير بورسونارو قد
خسر الانتخابات امام منافسه الزعيم اليسار
نهايه اكتوبر الماضي وغادر البلاد عشيه
حفل التنصيب دون تهنئه خصمه وتسليمه
الشعره الرئاسيه
متابعه تطورات معنا من مراسل الجزيره حسان
مسعود حسان ضعنا في سوره الواقعه
نعم اتحدث في هذه اللحظات
تجري عمليات اقتحام من قبل مؤيدين للرئيس
السابق جيير برسونارو في العاصمه
البرازيليه البرازيليه للمقار الحكوميه
الرئيسيه الثلاث في وسط العاصمه برازيليا
وهي مقر الحكومه الرئيسيه والقصر الرئاسي
الذي همم يدير فيه الرئيس البرازيلي شؤون
البلاد في العاصمه البرازيليه
ومبنى البرلمان الفيدرالي في العاصمه
البرازيليه وكذلك مبنى المحكمه الفيدراليه
العليا في هذه اللحظات يقوم محتجون
مؤيدونا لرئيس السابق جرير
لتنصيب الرئيس اليسرى الذي كان قد تم
تنصيبه الاحد الماضي للمره الثالثه في
تاريخه يقومون باقتحام هذا المبنى
ورصدت الصور التي اا انتشرت من داخل
المقارئ الحكوميه الرئيسيه الثلاث تكسير
وتحطيم للاثاث والمقتنيات في داخل هذه
المباني الحكوميه الثلاث بالاضافه الى
محاولات تخريب لهذه المباني وهمم جلوس همم
المحتجين على
الكراسي الرئيسيه همم
لاداره ورئاسه البرلمان الفدرالي
البرازيلي في مشهد يذكرنا بما حدث في
الكونجرس الامريكي بعد خساره دونالد ترامب
للانتخابات الرئاسيه الامريكيه هذا المشهد
كان همم يخشى ان يحدث وان تشهده البرازيل
بعد خساره الرئيس اليمنيه شهير في نهايه
اكتوبر الماضي امام منافسه الزعيم اليسا
في الانتخابات الا ان همم الاوضاع كانت ما
زال تحت السيطره خلال الفتره الماضيه
واستطاعت قوات الامن امن ان تمنع حدوث مثل
هذه الاحداث خلال الفتره الماضيه وشهدت
طرقات عديده في البرازيل قطع للطرقات ومنع
لي الحركه عند الطرقات الرئيسيه التي تربط
ما بين الولايات البرازيليه ولكن هذه
الحركه ايضا كانت توقفت بعد دعوه من
الرئيس السابق جير بورسونارو لفتح الطرقات
لانصاره الا ان هذه الاحداث عادت لتظهر
مره اخرى هناك في العاصمه البرازيليه كما
في عدد من المدن البرازيليه بما فيها همم
ولايه سوف التي يدعو فيها في هذه الاثناء
مؤيدوس نار الخروج الى الشوارع وتحديدا
الى المناطق همم المحيطه بالثقنات
العسكريه لمطالبه الجيش
الموجود
اليسار مجددا
نعم الرئيس الاولى دا سيلفا كان قد غادر
العاصمه برازيليه صباحا اليوم وتوجه الى
ولايه ساو باولو وتحديدا الى مدينه ارارك
كوارا هذه المدينه الواقعه في المناطق
الريفيه لسوفاول وكاله قد شهدت امطار
غزيره ادت الى مقتل خمسه اشخاص توجه
الرئيس لولا الى هناك لاطلاع على احوال
هذه المدينه وهذه البلده في داخل ولايه
سوفاولو
وحدثت هذه الاحداث في ظل غياب الرئيس لولا
عن العاصمه برازيليا حتى هذه اللحظه لم
تعلم الرئاسه او الجهات الامنيه عن مكان
وجود الرئيس البرازيلي لو دا سيلفا في
ولايه سوف اقول له نحن همم على همم على
علم بانه لم يعد الى عاصمه البرازيل
البرازيليه ما زال في ولايه سابالو الا ان
ما كانه بشكل واضح ليس همم معلومه حتى هذه
اللحظه ومن الجدير همم ذكره ايضا عبد
القادر ان المبنى الذي تم اقتحامه في
برازيليا هو مبنى اداره الحكم هو الرئاسيه
التي تدار منه البلاد الا ان قصر الرئاسيا
اخرا هو القصر الذي يسمى قصر الالفارادا
هو الذي يقيم فيه الرئيس همم الاولى دا
سيلفا او رئيس الجمهوريه البرازيليه بشكل
عام وهذه المنطقه حتى هذه اللحظه لم يستطع
المحتجون ان يصلوا اليها ولكن بكل الاحوال
فان هذا المشهد همم هو همم مشهد همم
يشير الى حاله من التوتر تعيشها البرازيل
كانت مرتقبه كان هناك خشيه من ان تحدث
ولكنها حدثت اليوم بعد اسبوع على تنصيب
الرئيس الاولى دا سيلفا هو سفر الرئيس
السابق عشيه التنصيب دون مشاركته بحفل
التنصيب او تسليمه لشارت الرئاسه وكذلك
دون تهنئه الرئيس حتى هذه اللحظه لم يعلن
بشكل واضح عن قبوله بالهزيمه وعن تهنيئته
للرئيس الفائز كما جاء البرازي الان
اي بيانات همم رسميه حتى الان فيما يتعلق
بهذه الاقتحامات وما يقوم به انصار الرئيس
همم بورسونارو فيما يتعلق بهذه المقرات
الرسميه في العاصمه البرازيليه
سلسله من البيانات من مختلف الاحزاب
البرازيليه ما عدا الاحزاب التي توصف هنا
بالاحزاب اليمنيه المتطرفه ادانت هذه همم
احتجاجات هذا الاقتحام للمقار الرئيسيه
همم البرازيليه وهي سابقه غير مسبوقه في
تاريخ البرازيل عبد القادر بالاضافه الى
دعوات من قبل الجميع لخروج هؤلاء من
الشوارع يشار الى ان البيانات وكذلك وسائل
الاعلام البرازيليه تشير وتصف هؤلاء
بالارهابيين كما يذكر حتى هذه اللحظه
والمجرمين وفقه توصيفه همم النعوت التي
ينعتون بها في هذه اللحظات منعا لتدفق
المزيد من المحتاجين المعارضين ل همم هذه
همم الاحتجاجات ويشار الى ايضا ان القوات
الامن تشتاب وتواجه همم هؤلاء باطلاق
الغاز المسيء للدموع وكذلك همم محاوله منع
من التقدم اكثر نحوه القصر الرئاسي راسيا
وانه وفور ظهور هذه الصور من العاصمه
برازيليه بدات لما يزيد من مؤيدين الرئيس
السابق جرير بولسناره للتوجه الى هذه
المناطق الرئيسيه في العاصمه البرازيليه
بالاضافه الى عدد من المدن كما ذكرنا من
بينها ايضا سوف اقول ما يعني انه من
المحتمل ان تتصاعد الامور وان تشهد البلاد
مواجهات اكثر في اكثر من منطقه وهو همم
ادى في اللحظات الاخيره قبل قليل الى همم
تعزيزات الامنيه ليس فقط في العاصمه
برازيلي انما ايضا في مدينه ساو باول وفي
عدد من الولايات البرازيليه التي كان كنا
قد ذكرنا بدايه انه فورا اعلان نتائج كان
هؤلاء قد عمده الى قطع الطرقات وشكلت تلك
المساله ازمه حقيقيه في الداخل البرازيلي
وعطلت البلاد بشكل كامل الا ان همم مؤيدوه
الرئيس همم جير بول سونار والرئيس السابق
كانوا قد انسحبوا من الشوارع لكنهم واصلوا
رفضهم لفوز الاولى دا سيلفابي الحكم وبعد
هذه همم هذا التنصيب حفل التنصيب الكبيره
الذي جرى الاسبوع الماضي همم كان هؤلاء قد
ايضا دعوا الجيش للتدخل ولمعه همم
حزب العمال واليسار من العوده الى الحكم
وفقا تعبيرهم ان نحن طيب تطورات التي يبدو
انها ستشهد همم حراكا
ماذا عن الاسئله المطروحه الان في وسائل
الاعلام البرازيليه خاصه وان ما يجري الان
كان متوقع ان هو اللهجه والتهديدات كانت
مطروحه في الايام الماضيه
نعم ما يجري الان هو التساؤل عن سبب تاخر
هذه ال ال الاحتجاجات هذا النوع من رده
الفعل الكبيره بالنسبه للبرازيل تاريخيا
وسياسيا منذ عوده الديمقراطيه الى
البرازيل في ثمانيات القرن الماضي عن
توقيت هذا التحرك لا سيما بعد خروج الرئيس
السابق جيد بالسونار من المشهد بعد بدء
عمل الحكومه البرازيليه التي كانت قد
اجتمعت بالفعل خلال همم الاسبوع الماضي
همم بكامل اعضائها من عشر احزاب مختلفه
تحكم البلاد برئاسه الرئيس الاولى دا
سيلفا الزعيم الازهري وهناك تساؤل عن سبب
وتوقيت هذا الاقتحام بالاضافه ايضا الى
الاشاره الى بعض الصور التي اظهرت الشرطه
لا تتفاعل بالشكل الذي كما ذكروه همم ذكره
عدد من السياسيين من الاضافه الى عدد من
وسائل الاعلام غير مفهومه همم
تفاعل من قبل الشرطه اا ليس بقدر الحجم
حجم الاحداث الكبيره التي كانت همم التي
تشهدها البلاد في هذه اللحظات هناك علامات
استفهام توضع على همم هذه التصرفات لا
سيما وان ولايه همم العاصمه الفيدراليه
ااه برازيليا هذه المنطقه التي تعتبر
وتسمى المقاطعه الفدراليه يحكمها شخصيه
مؤيده للرئيس السابق جرير وليست على وفاق
مع حزب العمال هذه المساله ايضا كانت تطرح
علامات استفهام عن كيفيه اداره المنطقه
والعاصمه همم البرازيليه خلال الفتره
المقبله في ظل هذا همم
الاختلاف في همم الحكم بين الرئيس الذي
يحكم البلاد ويقيم في داخل العاصمه وبين
همم حاكم الولايه الذي يؤيد جهه مخالفه
ومنافسه للرئيس يسري الحالي لولا ده سيلفا
ولكن بكل الاحوال همم المشهد الان هو مشهد
ترقب ومشهد همم محاوله لاحتواء هذه همم
الاحداث غير المعتاده في البرازيل غير وان
كانت متوقعه ولكنها صادمه كما توصف عبر
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي وكذلك عبر وسائل
الاعلام
مباشره من هناك من ال- هناك نقطه عندما
يطلب انصار الرئيس السابق بنارو من الجيش
ان يتدخل لان لا يصل الرئيس
يسار الى السلطه هناك علامه استفهام كيف
يفهم في البرازيل في البرازيل هذه الدعوه
للجيش لان يمنع رئيس منتخب من ان يجلس على
كرسي ويستلم مهامه كرئيس للدوله
نعم عبد القادر هذه المساله ليست منفصله
وليست دعوه جديده هذه الدعوه كانت منذ
فتره حكم الرئيس جيد بونارو كانت هذه
الدعوات من قبل مؤيدي برشلونه الجهه التي
تعتبر جبهه متطرفه كما توصفون في الاعلام
البرازيلي من مؤيدي الرئيس جيد سونار
وكانوا يدعونا خلال فتره حكم برشلونه
لتدخل الجيش لصالحه
لنظرا لعوده الرئيس لولا ده سيلفا الى
المشهد السياسي
لالغاء الاحكام التي كانت صدرت بحقه بتهم
الفساد واعاده همم
حقوق السياسيه
للرئيس الحالي الاولى دا سيلفا منذ هذه
اللحظات منذ هذه الاحداث كان مؤيدوبه
سونار يدعون لتدخل الجيش لصالحه ويدعونا
لوقف المحكمه الفدراليه العليا التي كانت
ابطلت الاحكام عن الرئيس اليسرى
لوقوفي الجيش الى جانب الرئيس همم جرير
بولسونارو وهذه الدعوات تكررت في اكثر من
مناسبه في اكثر من مشهد على المستوى
البرازيلي وكان الرئيس جرير ايضا حذر من
عدم قبوله همم نتائج الانتخابات في حال
كانت اللجنه مخصصه قد شكلت من الجيش
البرازيلي همم لمراقبه الانتخابات قد ايه
اعلنت عدم صحه نتائج الانتخابات الا ان
هذه اللجنه بذاتها كانت قد اعلنت تاكدت ان
نتائج الانتخابات صحيحه وان هذه همم
الارقام التي حصل عليها مرشح اليسار وعاد
فيها الى الحكومه كانت همم بفارق مليونان
صوت فقط عن منافسه جرير همم كانت همم
ارقامنا صحيحه وهو بالفعل رئيس فعلي
البرازيل بشكل الديمقراطي وهو وهي اشاره
واضحه كانت من الجيش الى عدم موا على او
استجابته لهذه الدعوات وايضا ما اختلف
الان ان الجيش البرازيلي تغيرت قيادته بعد
عوده الاولى دا سيلفا وتسلمها همم قائد
للجيش همم معين من قبل الرئيس همم لولا ده
سيلفا ويختلف عن قائد الجيش الذي كان يحكم
البلاد خلال او كان يحكم الجيش البرازيلي
ويتراس الجيش البرازيلي خلال فتره حكم جير
برو سونارو هذه ايضا الدعوات ربما لن تلقى
اذان صاغيه خلال هذه الفتره نظرا لتغير
القياده العسكريه كانت ربما مفهومه في
البرازيل عند الفتره الماضيه خلال الفتره
حكم الجيش ما قبل تسليمه او قبل تسلم لولا
ده سيلفا الحكم همم بدايه العام الجاري في
حفل تنصيب ولكن في هذه اللحظات هذه
الدعوات ربما تكون ايضا دعوات غير مفهومه
خلال اللحظات الحاليه وهي همم تعيد
الذاكره للبرازي لفتره من الحكم
الديكتاتوريه الذي كان قد حكم البلاد خلال
ثمانيات من القرن الماضي همم
رئيس دوله سيلفا موجود في صفاوله ولكن لا
احد يعلم بالتحديد اين هو الى الان رغم
انه لم يمر الى وقت ليس بالكثير ولكن هي
يعني وقت صعب جدا في البرازيل الى الان
همم لم يظهر اي كلمه او بيان من قبل
الرئيس لولا ده سيلفا حتى الان ما القراءه
ما المؤشرات حتى الان مما يدل على صعوبه
ما يجري الان في البرازيل
نعم نحن نتوقع ان يكون الرئيس سيلولا الان
في طريقه من المنطقه التي كان قد زرى كما
ذكرنا وهي ارر كوارا وهي مدينه نائيه في
ولايه ساو باولو في طريقه للعوده الى
عاصمه ولايه سوفاولو على الاقل او الى
مكان امنا اخر يختاره فريقه الامني وربما
هذا السبب الذي لم يؤدي او لم يدفع الرئيس
الاولى لتصريح حتى هذه اللحظه بالاضافه
طبعا الى الاعتبارات الكثيره لهذه المساله
والى الحساسيه الكبيره نحن نتحدث عن مشهد
غير مسبوق في تاريخ البرازيل عندما يدخل
المحتجون الى داخل همم صالات القصر
الرئاسي يحطمون اجزاء من اثاثه يعبثون
بمحتوياته ومن المعروف ان المدينه العاصمه
برازيلي التي انشئت قبل 60 عاما فقط وهي
عاصمه حديثه اخترت البرازيل لتكون من طاقه
مركزيه بعدما كانت العاصمه هي ريو دي
جانيرو هذه المنطقه اسست بشكل حر كانت
عندما اسسها اوسكار نيمار المهندس الكبير
المعروف والمشهور في البرازيل اسسها لتكون
منطقه مساحات مفتوحه بين الشعب وهمم
الرئاسه وبين السلطه وكانت في ساحه معروفه
بانها ساحت السلطات الثلاث وجميع هذه
الساحات هي مفتوحه على القصور القصر
الرئاسي وكذلك البرلمان وكذلك همم مجلس
همم او مبنى المحكمه الفيدراليه لذلك
استطاع المحتجون ان يدخلوا بسهوله الى هذه
المنطقه بعد كسرهم وتحطهم وتحطيمهم للزجاج
هذه القصور هذا مشهد غير مسبوق هذا مشهد
همم لم تلفه البرازيل حتى في ظل فتره
الديكتاتوريه قبل عوده الديمقراطيه بشكلها
الحالي لم يكن هذا المشهد مالوفا ان يدخل
المحتاجون الى همم القصور بهذا الشكل وان
يحطم الاثاث وان يجلس على كرسي البرلمان
وهم يرتدون الزي الاصفر وهي الزي الذي
تعارف عليه واعتاد مؤيدوه الرئيس جارينارو
وهذا ما يدل على حساسيه الوضع امنيا
سياسيا وان
ينتظره البرازيليون اليوم هو كيفيه تعامل
سلطات السلطات الامنيه القوات الامنيه همم
ربما قد يتدخل الجيش في حاله تم استدعائه
من قبل القائد الاعلى للقوات المسلحه في
البرازيل وهو الرئيس همم البرازيلي الاولى
ده سيلفا ربما ربما البعد عندما كنا نتابع
قبل لحظات كان يتحدث عن احتمال اعلان او
ضروره اعلان حاله الطوارئ في مثل هذه همم
احداث للتعامل مع المساله كانت حاله
الطوارئ عده مرات في عدد من الولايات عند
الكوارث الانسانيه كما ك- كمثل هذه
الكارثه التي يزورها كان يزورها الرئيس
الذي تاخذه
ايضا للمتابعه هذه التطو في البرازيل
وتحديدا ما يجب العاصمه برازيليه اذ نذكر
بتطورات وقد اقتحم محتاج جون مؤيدون
للرئيس البرازيلي السابق جرير بورسونارو
القصر الرئاسي ومقر الحكومه ومبنى
البرلمان ومبنى المحكمه الفيدراليه في
العاصمه البرازيليه رفضا لتنصيب الرئيس
الاولى دا سيلفا وتخلل الاقتحام وقوع
مواجهات بين المحتجين والشرطه وقطع
المحتجون عددا من الطرق في برازيليا
واستخدمت قوات الشرطه الغاز المسيله
للدموع بتفريق المحتاجين جدير بالذكر ان
الرئيس سيلفا غير موجود داخل القصر
الرئاسي في برازيليا حيث يزور اليها سوفو
وكان الرئيس السابق جرير سونارو قد خسر
الانتخابات امام منافسه الزعيم اليسرى
نهايه اكتوبر الماضي وغادر البلاد عشيه
حفل التنصيب دون تهنئه خصمه وتسليمه اشاره
الرئاسيه
معنا منا سوف اولو علي فرحات الصحفي
المختص بالشان البرازيل سيد علي كيف تصف
ما يجري في هذه اللحظات خاصه في العاصمه
البرازيليه
يبدو ان هناك قرار قرارا سياسيا على مستوى
عالم تجمع عليه القيمه السياده في هذه
الظاهره
وعده بمعاقده وهو يعني بالمناسبه ومن
المؤيدين
وبالتالي من الممكن ان تتم اقاله وزير
الامن في ولايه سنطوله في حكومه الولايه
وهو اندرس على خلفيه هذه الاحداث
ولك يا سيد علي حتى هناك دعوات في سوفاوله
الانصار ايضا للخروج والاحتجاج
ات لا تغطيه السياسيه من الجهات من
الاحجار
ولا حتى من النواب اللي كانوا الذين يعني
ينتمون الى نفس حزمه برشلونه
والتظاهرات وايضا همم الحاله البوستوريه
حيث
سيحاسب المسؤولون عن هذا الامر يمكن ان
يكون هناك اقاله لحاكم صوتاله او على
الاقل
خصوصا ان هناك اجماعا سياسيا على ان ما
حصل هو معادي للامن البرازيلي ولل للسلام
الاجتماعي
شكرا لكم علي فرحات الصحفي المختص بشان
البرازيلي وكذلك الشكر لمراسل الجزيره من
سوف اول حسان مسعود
[موسيقى]
الى سودان وفيها انطلقت المرحله النهائيه
للعمليه السياسيه
للحوار للسودان والتي تتالف من الاتحاد
الافريقي ومجموعه ايجاد وبعثه الامم
المتحده ان هذه المرحله سيحضرها المدنيون
والعسكريون المواقعون على اتفاق الاطار
السياسيه وقد اكد المشاركون ان المباحثات
ستشمل اطرافا من خارجي الجهات الواقعه على
الاتفاق
ومع بدء اعمال المرحله النهائيه التي
ستستمر مشاوراتها اربعه ايام قال رئيس
مجلس السياده عبد الفتاح البرهان ان
المؤسسه العسكريه لن تتراجع عن ما تعاهدت
به بالانسحاب من المشهد السياسي وتسليم
قياده مرحله الانتقال السياسي للمدنيين
واضاف ان المؤسسه العسكريه ستدفع بباقي
القوه السياسيه والمدنيه للالتحاق
بالمصاري السياسيه
مجددا ان المؤسسه العسكريه ملتزمه التزام
كامل بخروجها وملتزمه ايضا بالعمل مع
شركائنا
السياسيين والمدنيين بوضع الاسس والقطر
التي تؤثر عمل المؤسسه العسكريه في
المجتمعات الديمقراطيه نحن المؤمنين
مؤمنين ايمان ترام بان القوات المسلحه هي
جزء من قوه الدوله التي يجب ان يتشارك
الجميع في ادارتها وعاجلا ام اجلا ستخضع
لامره السلطه المدنيه التي تنتج عن
الانتخابات
هذا وكاله قوه الحريه والتغيير الكتله
الديمقراطيه قالت انها اوقفت اللقاءات غير
المباشره مع مجموعه الحريه والتغيير
المجلس المركزي وقال مبارك اردو لان
الناطق الرسمي باسم الكتله الديمقراطيه ان
الاتفاق الايطالي بشكله الحالي مرفوض
اللقاءات التي دارت بيننا وبين المكونه
العسكري مبادره الرئيس رئيس المجلس
السيادي والغائد العام للقوات المسلحه
الفريق البرهان جلسنا في اكثر من ثلاثه
جالسات
والجلسات كانت يعني يعني تحدثنا سلمناه
موقف في البدايه وموقف تمثل مثل مواقف
الكتله الديمقراطيه مكتوب وكنا يعني
خيارات امامنا مفتوحه حاليا اوقفنا اي
نقاش غير رسمي لاهميه انه لا يجب ان يعني
يتحدث الناس او يتم يعني همم استنطاق حديث
غير حقيقي فيما يدور
ورحب بيضيفيه من الخرطوم الدكتور ناجي
مصطفى المتحدث باسمي مبادره نداء اهل
السودان وامنه الخرطوم ايضا ياسر عرفان
رئيس الحركه الشعبيه التيار الثوري
الديمقراطي والمتحدث باسمي قوه الحريه
والتغيير المجلس المركزي اهلا بكم وابدا
معكم دكتور ناجي مصطفى محاوله فهم لماذا
الرفض في المشاركه في هذه المشاورات التي
تحظى بتوافق الدولي توافق اقليمي وكذلك
تعهد من قبل المكون العسكري بالانسحاب من
المشهد السياسي
نعم التحيه لك
الاخر وتحيل الشعب السوداني
المصدوم بهذا الراهن السياسي غير المتوقع
في الحقيقه اجابه على هذه السؤال اولا ااا
نحن لا نرى تاييد دولي ولا اقليمي ولا
داخلي الحفله التي
الاطراف
الحفله الاحتفال الذي تم قبل قليل ادعيت
له مجموعات كبيره من السفارات هذا يستطيع
اي سوداني في زواج ابنته ان يدعو السفراء
فياتون اليه في بيته هذه هذه الواجهات
التي تعبر عن رضا اقليمي هؤلاء السفراء
وهم سفراء في السودان وهم ياتون الى اي
مناسبه انا اعتبر الدعم الاقليمي هو الدعم
الجاد والموقف السياسي الواضح المبرد وهذا
همم ليس موجود الا من مجموعه التوريكا
ومجموعه الرباعيه وهذه المجموعات هي
المجموعات تعريف انها تتحاور وتج النفاقات
مع جماعات اقصائيه وهي اقليه من اقليه هذه
المجموعه الان التي تريد ان توقع هذا
الاتفاق الهزلي وقعت من قبل اتفاقا وكانت
مجموعه اكبر من هذه المجموعه الحريه
والتغيير كانت كتله واحده الحركات المسلحه
لم تكن معارضه كنا نحن ايضا مساندين
لعمليه التوقيع الاتفاق الميثاق الوثيقه
الدستوريه ومعه هذا فشلت هذه الوثيقه
واطيح بها طاح بها الرجل مثل تيريك وتحالف
الحركات المسلحه امام القصر وغيرها من
الان كلها هؤلاء خارج هذه التوقيع
ويعارضونهم وينضم اليهم من لجان المقاومه
والحزب الشيوعي والسنهوري والحزب وغير ذلك
همم ياسر عرفات
ما فائده هذا التوافق الدولي او الاقليمي
اذا كان الموقف الداخلي بهذا المستوى من
الانقسام وبالتالي اما مصير هذه المشاورات
اولا لو كنت اعلى منه هذا هو الضيف الذي
كنت تستضيفه معي لما تشمت متاعب
المجيء
وينكر ضوء الشمس همم ليس عن رمد
من مجموعات الفلول والمؤتمر الوطني لم
تعظم باي همم دعم الحديث عن انه هذا
التعريف
الثاني هنا بشكل شخصي للتعبير عن مواقفهم
الشخصيه كل طرف منكم يمثل وبالتالي لنقطه
في اطار السؤال لو تكررت
يتحدث في الفضاء العام
السؤال الذي طرحته واضح وضوح الشمس
والدوليه معتبره عن تاييدها للاتفاق
الايطالي هذه الدول
وحكومات تتحدث عن نفسه وتحدثت وفي وجود كل
القياده المدنيه والعسكريه ولذلك الحديث
السيد ياسر انا سالتك رغم هذا الاتفاق
الدولي والاقليمي ما قيمته اذا كان هناك
انقسام داخلي
الانسان الداخلي يجب ان تحليله وتحليل جيد
الضيفه
الشعب السوداني ولا يتفق مع حتى الحزب
الشيوعي ولا يتفق مع حتى حزب البعث وحتى
الناس من عارضين لهذه
شخصيه
الموجوده في المشهد السياسي السوداني
وترفض هذه المشاورات وهذا الايطار كما
سمته في شكله الحالي
غالبيه قوى الثوره مؤيده للوصول الى حكم
مدني الديمقراطي هذا هو جوهره العمليه
التي جرت اليوم وجرت في الانتفاض الايطالي
هذا ما يسمى بقوه الثوره اما هو النظام
القديم التي تريد ان ترجع الشماليه والتي
حاولت وجربت وغامت بمبادرات هذه الغلام في
المسرح السياسي الاتفاق الحالي
بدعم كبير بدعم كبير بدعم داخلي كبير
وكافي طيب
ما فائده هذه المواقف اذا كان المراد هو
اخراج المشهد السياسي من هذا الانسداد
الذي هو في هل الحل باعطاء هذه المواقف
ووصف ما يجري بانه مجرد
مسرحيه بائسه او عرس فاشل كما ذكرت
جيد حتى اجيبك بشفافيه وصدق نحن ضد هذا
الاتفاق الايطالي ليس لانه هو يعني جاء من
الخارج او هو اقصى كما اقصى الان المتحدث
يقول ما كان سياتي ل- ليناقش العقليه
الاقصائيه نحن ضد هذا الاتفاق لانه هو ميت
اصلا ما هي مقومات الحياه الموجوده في هذه
الاتفاق وانا اتحدى ياسر عرفات بتاريخ
الطويل السياسي ما هي مؤهلات نجاحه هذا
الاتفاق هو جزء صغير من اتفاق تم التوقيع
عليه من قبل بين نفس المكونات وحكمه
السودان 26 شهر كانت اسوا اشهر حكم
السودان بشهاده كل السوداني اسال اي
سوداني عندكم انتم همم
هذه السنوات التي حكمت باتفاق سابق هو
صوره من هذه الاتفاق كانت السنوات
السوداني نفس الاشخاص نفس التفكير نفس
الفعل
نعم
الحل يا اخي الكريم اولا انت سالتني سؤال
سابق وانا ما اجبت عليه انه نحنا لماذا
اضفت هذا الاتفاق اظن اني اجبت الان ال ال
الحل يا اخي الكريم ان نخرج من هذه من هذه
الحاله اللساني الذي يعبر عنه ياسر عرفات
نادي مصطفى من المؤتمر الوطني الفنون
السابق يا اخي الكريم اسال الشعب السوداني
مصطفى وياسر عرمان من الذي كان في
البرلمان مع المؤتمر الوطني رئيس كتله من
الذي جلس مع المؤتمر الوطني وحاورهم وقع
معاهم اتفاق يعني
الشخصيه شكرا شكرا
دكتور ناجي مصطفى المتحدث باسم مبادره
نداء اهل السودان
رئيس الحركه الشعبيه التيار الديمقراطي
والمتحدث باسم القوه الحريه والتغيير
المجلس المركزي شكرا
[موسيقى]
ضربه انتقاميه هكذا تصف موسكو ما اعلنت
عنه من انه هجوم العوده بحياه مئات الجنود
الاخرانيين بعد مقتل العشرات من جنوده في
ليله راس السنه هذا ما تقوله موسكو لكن
حديث اخر ينفي ان يكون قد سقط مئات من
جنودك وبموازته سيجال التطورات البيدانيه
تحتدم المعارك على اكثر من جبهه غير ان
ذلك لم يحل دون ابرامي صفقه لتبادل اسرى
من الجانبين
تنتقم روسيا
تقول وزاره الدفاع هناك كانها قتلت اكثر
من 600 عسكريين اوكرانيا
في مايكيفك بجمهوريه دوميتك الشعبيه خلال
الدقائق الاولى من السنه الجديده نفذنا
عمليه الانتقاليه
89 جنديا روسيا بقصف اوكرانيه الضربات
الروسيه
وتلك مدينه استراتيجيه تسيطر عليها القوات
الاوكرانيه وتعتبر عاصمتها المؤقته في
اقليم دونيت في الحديث عن اكرام تيرسك
تشتد المعارك في مدينه سوليدار تسعى
القوات الاوكرانيه لوقف التقدم الروسي
هناك لمنع تحديد اكرام التوست من الجهه
الشرقيه متحدث باسم قياده المنطقه الشرقيه
الاخرانيه قال للجزيره انه لا يمكن القول
ان سلدار تحت سيطره الجيش الروسي
لكن ثنتا قلق اوكراني قادم من الشمال تزيد
القوات الروسيه والبيلاروسيه وتيره
مناورتهم العسكريه تستنفر اوكرانيا لحمايه
العاصمه رغم تاكيدات بلا روسيه ان
المناورات لا تهدف للمشاركه في الحرب لكن
التصريحات نفسها سمعت من بلا روسيا وروسيا
قبل احد عشر شهرا حينها كانت الاراضي
البيلاروسيه نقطه انطلاق للحرب لا يوقف
القتال احاديث السياسيه سيجتمع الطرفان في
تركيا هذا ما يؤكده الجانب الاوكراني على
الاقل
ستعقد تلك المباحثات في غضون ايام قليله
على الاراضي التركيه
وستركز اساسا على ملف الاسره بين الجانبين
وعوده اسرارنا الابطال
قبل انطلاقه هذه المحادثات تكررت عمليات
التبادل الاسرى 50 جنديا من كلا الجانبين
افرج عنهم ليعود الى ديارهم تطوى في الوقت
نفسه صفحه اول هدنه في الحرب استمرت لست
وثلاثين ساعه بعد ان اعلن عنها الرئيس
الروسي من جانب واحد ورفضها نظيره
الاوكرانيه يعلن لكريم لنا ان القوات
الروسيه ماضيه في تحقيق اهداف عمليتها
العسكريه الخاصه المهام قيد الانجاز
وروسيا ستنتصر هذا ما يقوله النائب الاول
لرئيس الديوان الرئاسي الروسي
هكذا يتواصل القتال في الجنوب والقلق من
الشمال والبحث عن وساطه توقف الحرب ولو
مؤقتا
عد كثيرا عن نتداعيه حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا حيث قال رئيس الوزراء السويدي
اولف كريسترسون ان تركيا طلبت اشياء لا
يمكن تلبيتها للموافقه على انضمام السويد
للنيتو واكد بالمقابل فرقه بلاده من ان
تركيا ستوافق على طلب انضمام السويد
ايضا انها تريد اشياء لا يمكننا تقديمها
القرار الان متروكيه
من واشنطن معنا روبرتو انت راس سفير
الامريكيه السابق لدى النت هو كبير
الباحثين في مركز العلاقات عبر الاطلسي
اهلا بك سيد روبرت كيف وجدت هذا الرد من
قبل السويد على مطالب قناه انها لا تستطيع
الموافقه عليها وبعضها لا تريد ان تقوم به
في الحقيقه هناك عمليه تفاوض تجري الان
بين السويد وبين تركيا بالنسبه الى سماح
تركيا
في حلف شمال الاطلسي وبالتالي كل ما يقال
الان ليس نهائيا في حقيقه الامر
كلا الطرفين يعمل على صيغه معينه تركيا ان
تتاكد من ان السويد لا تدعم حزب العمال
الكردستاني باي شكل من الاشكال وايضا ان
تتاكد من عدم معارضه تركيا للضمام السويد
الى ابنته اعتقده ان العاصمتين سوف
تتوصلان الى حل القضيه
نقاط الخلاف حتى الان همم يمكن التفاوض
حولها ام انها نقاط
جوهريه رئيسيه صعب ان تتجاوزها انقره
ان يفهم انا اييي تركيا تتشدد في موقفها
لانها تعرف انه من غير الاساسيه بالنسبه
الى السويد ان تصبح دوله عضو في حلف شمال
الاطلسي فنلندا الامر اهم بالنسبه اليها
لانها على الحدود مع روسيا ولكن اذا ما
اراد الرئيس بوتن ان يهاجم السويد يجب ان
يمر بفرندا اولا في الماضي تركيا قالت
انها ليست مساله حيويه جوهريه بالنسبه الى
حلف شمال الاطلسي لذلك تفاوض بهذا الشات
بموقف متشدد نحن في مرحله
تفاوضيه ولكن اعتقد ان الجانبين سوف
يتوصلان الى حل بهذا الخصوص لا اعتقده
اننا وصلنا الى ثقف النهائي من كلا
الطرفين منا واشنطن روبرت عن درس سفير
الامريكيه السابق لدى نيته كبير الباحثين
في مركز العلاقات عبر الاطلسي
[موسيقى]
نظمها اكبر الاحزاب الصربيه في كوسوفو
مظاهرات جنوبيه البلاد للتنديد باطلاق
شرطي النار على اثنين من الاقليه الصربيه
وقال الرئيس السردي اليكساندر فوشيش ان
قوات حفظ السلام التي يقودها حالف شمال
الاطلسي رفض الطلب بلاده ارسال الجنود الى
قصه لحمايه الاقليه الصربيه
سيربو كوسوفي غاضبون نظمت اكبر احزاب
الاقليه العرقيه هذا الاعتصام جنوبي
البلاد جاءوا بالالاف لتمديد باصابه اثنين
منهم برصاص شرطي من الاغلبيه الالباني
تمكن من العيش هنا يجب ان لا يتكرر ذلك
مجددا
هذه عائله الفتى المصاب تنفي كل ما اشيع
عن اغلاق الطريق قبل حادث اطلاق النار
عندما راني مع خالته انهار باكيا ولكن ما
الذي يمكننا فعله الحمد لله انه مازال حيا
ونحن سعداء لذلك
ايام العام في عيد ميلاد المسيح
[موسيقى]
من الاحتجاجات الصربيه الشماليه البلاد
هدات بفضل التدخلات دوليه بما سمح باعاده
فتح الطرق والمعابر والدفع باتجاه الحوار
بين الطرفين حكومه كوسوفي واعتقلت الشرطي
المشتبه فيه هو تحقق معه بينما كشف الرئيس
الصربي الاجسام ان قوات حفظ السلام
الدوليه رفض الطلبه وارسال جنود سرب الى
كوسوفو لحمايه المدنيين قال ان قرار مجلس
الامن رقم
1,144 يخوله ارسال 1,000 جندي لكن القرار
صدر في التسعينيات القرن الماضي قبل ان
تعلن كسوف استقلالها وبين سجل الحكومتين
يحاول الناس هنا ان يحافظوا على تبقى من
سلم اهلي
اطلاق النار الذي وقع هنا يخشى ان يتحول
الى مفترق طرق يغير مسار الهدوء الذي تحقق
بعد اسابيع من التوترات فحوادث تبدو عربيه
كهذه شكلت في مرات كثيره سابقا شراره
لاضطرابات استمرت اشهر سنوات محمد المدهون
الجزيره من جنوبي كتب
اكاديمي والخبير في العلاقات
ما اهم العوامل التي تساعد في تسخين الوضع
اكثر فاكثر
يا صفار صفاد القاهره
عندما نتحدث عن ازمه كوسوفو يجب ان نعرف
انها معقده بشكل اكبر بكثير بعيدا عن مجرد
هذه الحادثه يجب ان نظهر بهذه الازمه في
اطار الصوره الاجمل نحن نتحدث عن حادث اتى
بعد سلسله من التراكمات والحوادث وما نراه
الان هو تظهير او الصوره لهذه الازمه
المعقده التي يمكن ان تشهد تصعيدا في اي
لحظه الطرفان همم في كوسوفو وفي صربيا
يمكنهما ان يتصرف في اي مرحله بشكل يتسبب
بحصول حادث للوصول الى نزاع مفتوح مثال
على ذلك الرئيس الصديق بطلابه بنشر القوات
الصربيه في قصر وهو طلب طبعا تم رفضه كما
اشرتب ومن الاهميه بمكان ان نقول ان
الرئيس الصردي يستخدم هذه الحادثه
كاستراتيجيه او هذه الطريقه كستراتيجيه
للتعامل مع الازمه وهذا يمكن ان يكون خطرا
للغايه بالنسبه الى الطرفين يمكنهما ان
ينزلقا الى الاذاعه المفتوح وايضا الى
المنطقه الان موجود منذ سنوات في هذه
الرقعه الجغرافيه بشكل مباشر الى اي مدى
ما يجري في كتفه يتاثر بشكل مباشر ما يجري
تحديدا في الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه الان
وتداعياتها على اوروبا
بوينت
للغايه في الحقيقه
الوضع يتاثر
بالمؤثرات الخارجيه بشكل كبير في هذه
المنطقه اعتقد ان استراتيجيه الرئيس
الروسي
مدعومه بشكل كبير امم في حقيقه الامر
تحاول روسيا ان تبقي على التوترات لكي
ينشغل حلف شمال الاطلسي بشكل كبير في هذه
المنطقه لذلك اتوقع ان استفزازات مماثله
سوف تستمر وسوف تشهدها بشكل مستمر نحن لا
نتفاجئ همم
موقف من قبل
تجاهها الرئيس
اذا نظري بهذه
الازمه يجب ان ناخذها كجزء من الاحجيه
الاوسع بنسبه الى الوضع الجيو السياسي في
المنطقه شكرا لك واعتذر منك ادركنا الوقت
من سرايبو اليكوجلك الاكاديمي والخبير في
العلاقات الدولي
[موسيقى]
قال وزير الخارجيه الفلسطيني رياضه
المالكي ان السلطات الاسرائيليه سحبت
تصريح العبور الخاص به يضمن مجموعه
اجراءات عقابيه ضد السلطه الفلسطينيه
واضاف المالكيه ان السلطه الفلسطينيه تدرس
الخطوات القانونيه والسياسيه المقبله للرد
على الاجراءات العقابيه الاسرائيليه بسبب
لجوء السلطه الفلسطينيه الى محكمه العدل
الدوليه واكد المالكي في تصريحات الاذاعيه
ان اجراءات الاحتلال مخالفه للقانون
الدولي وتاتي ردا على حق طبيعيه
لدوله فلسطين للخلاص من الاحتلال المتواصل
منذ عقوده
من الناصره محمود يزبك استاذ الدراسه
الدراسات الشرق الاوسط في جامعه حيفا
دكتور محمود في ايطار تضع هذه الاجراءات
الاسرائيليه بل والتهديد باجراءات اكثر
تسعيدا اذا ما مضت السلطه الفلسطينيه في
قرار هذه بيتعلق بمحكمه العدل الدوليه
الابطال العامه
الجناح الفاشل في الحكومه الاسرائيليه
وضعف نتنياهو الذي لا يستطيع ان يكفي
امامه هؤلاء ووقف اجراءاتهم والحكومه
الاسرائيليه ككل الان يعني عمليه تخشى مما
قامت به السلطه الفلسطينيه وهذا تحدي
الامام السلطه الفلسطينيه باعتقاده ان
تستمر بهذه النهج بالاستمرار في التوجه
للمحكمه العدل الدوليه والكفعه الاسرائيلي
ما تفعله لانه في المرات السابقه حينما
كانت تتوجه الفلسطينيه
واسرائيل تعتقد انه من خلال الضغط على
السلطه الفلسطينيه من خلال يعني السحب
رخصه الفي اي بي من الشخصيات او يعني سرقه
تبقى القنص بعض من الاموال الفلسطينيه
وقرصنه هذه الاموال تستطيع ان تركع السلطه
الفلسطينيه الشعب الفلسطيني الان انا
اعتقد يقف مع السلطه الفلسطينيه والسؤال
والتحدي الاكبر هو امام السلطه الفلسطينيه
ان تقف امامنا اليوم وحكومه الياهو وانت
تجننت العالم العربي خاصه
امام مع الجانبه الاسرائيلي هناك ايضا
اتصالات دوليه اوروبيه امريكيه هناك حديث
ربما حتى على ان ربما وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه قد يزور المنطقه في ظل محاوله
التخفيف من هذا الوضع ماذا عن هذا البعد
نعم انا اعتقد ان هو البعد دول وخاصه يعني
الامريكي وتجميده الاجانب الفلسطيني هام
جدا في هذه المرحله من اجل التغلب على
التهديدات الاسرائيليه والاجراءات
الاسرائيليه الاجراءات الاسرائيليه ستتصعب
من اليوم صاعدا ولذلك السلطه الفلسطينيه
مطالبه بشكل واضح ان تقف امام هذا هذا
التصاعد الاسرائيلي وهذه السياسه
الاسرائيليه
حيث شكرا لك
رفعت الصين الحجر الصحيه الالزاميه
للمسافرين الوافدين من الخارج وبذلك وضعت
حدا لعزله فرضتها على نفسها منذ 3 سنوات
للسيطره على تفشي وباء كرونه
كل الطرق تؤدي الى الصين جوا وبرا وبحرا
فلا بوابات مقصده ولا حجرا صحيا مطلوبا
لقد قررت البلاد انهاء عزلتها والانفتاح
مجددا على العالم بعد ثلاث سنوات من
القيود الصارمه والمرهقه لمجابهه جائحه
كورونا
انا متحمس للغايه لقد مرت ثلاث سنوات منذ
عوده الى الوطن الام اخر مره بسبب كوفي 19
في المطارات اختفت الحواجز التي كانت تفصل
بين الرحلات الدوليه والداخليه وتخلى
الموظفون عن بالذاتهم الواقيه التي لا
زمتهم منذ فرض سياسي صفر كوفيت
رفعت معظم القيود المفروضه عند الحدود بين
بر الصين الرئيسي وهون كونج وسمح لنحو 60
الف شخص بالسفر في الاتجاهين يوميا مع
اقتراب حلول العام القمري الجديد
صباحا استقبل تشانغهاي وهي اكبر مدينه في
الصين اول رحله طيران الدوليه قادمه من
نيوزيلندا لا يتوجب على القادمين اليوم
سوى اظهار رمز يثبت انهم سجلوا اختبار
كوبيه 19 سلبيا في غضون 48 ساعه قبل
المغادره مطار العاصمه الدوليه الرئيسي في
بيجين وصلته الاحد ثمان رحلات خارجيه
وينتظر ان يستقبل المزيد بعد ارتفاع
الحجوزات منذ اعلان السلطات الصينيه الشهر
الماضي فجاه الغاء معظم القيود قرار رفع
القيود وهو استداره هائله في سياسه الصين
الوبائيه تخطى اعتباراته الصحيه الى ابعاد
اجتماعيه باعتباره اذانا بلم شمل بعض
الاسر والاحبه بعد افتراق دام ثلاثه اعوام
والقرار ايضا محاوله للتعافي الاقتصادي
بعد سنوات الاغلاق والعزله
كويسه
اعتقد انها خطوه ضروريه لقد اصبحت في
الطبيعيين الان وبعد هذه العقبه سيكون كل
شيء سلسا
لكن الخطوه تواجه عقبات كثيره بينها موجه
اصابات جديده متفاقبه ادت الى وفايات
واكتراض المستشفيات لا سيما في المدن
الكبرى وهو ما دفع عددا من دول العالم الى
وضع قيود على سفر الصينيين اليها بذريعه
تكتم بجينا على حقيقه المشهد الوبائي
الراهن في اكبر بلد في العالم من حيث عدد
السكان
واول بكره لظهور فايروس
كتاب الحصاد للقاء
[موسيقى]